looks like city
ciudad perdida the lost city is high up
in Colombia's most isolated mountain
range the Sierra Nevada
archeologists have spent decades
exploring this dense jungle to find out
about the people who lived here over
five hundred years ago
digital technology will help them reveal
more and faster
only the world's toughest archaeologists
can handle this terrain Santiago Giraldo
has been excavating here for 20 years
it's amazing this place is still
standing we discovered it it was like a
doze looters and then the archaeologists
came in took him about a week to get
here and they were led by other looters
looters led the way huh yeah it's
actually pretty incredible because they
were they got into a shotgun fight
looters were after the gold that's in
the burials and one looter came out with
you know more than 80 pieces of gold
from one burial yeah
gunfights for gold archaeology gets
dangerous and gold is involved and this
place is bursting with it who built all
this
those are people that we call the
Daytona their predecessors began to be
built around 600 AD it's huge
[Music]
how many people would have lived here -
just three thousand at its peak and then
about ten thousand people living in the
upper part of the basin ten thousand
yeah all that force that you see would
have been all farmland
ah man you'd almost feel their energy
here you know like all these people
running around
[Music]
it's taken us over 40 years of work to
clear out and survey the site trying to
tease out what these people were
thinking when they were building it 40
years
[Music]